everything in life is genetics all
living things are made of genes the
trees the beautiful flowers we smell our
favorite pets all of these are made up
of genes which control our traits and
how we behave my name is Mike Schneider
I'm professor and chair of genetics at
Stanford University I'm also the
director for the center for genomics and
personalized medicine in this class
we're gonna learn what is genetics why
should we bother studying it it's a
study of life and the way it is and how
traits are passed from one person to the
next it's a study of natural inherited
traits our hair color or eye colors our
personalities all these are controlled
by genetics we're also gonna have a
better understanding of how diseases
work and how to take charge of your
health and you need to know genetics in
order to think about disease and how to
treat yourself and others and in fact
this information is very very critical
for health in the future the adventure
is about to begin you're gonna learn all
the way from DNA to its product the
proteins and RNA and we're gonna learn
about how things work in the natural
world so we can better understand the
world around us including ourselves